in a romantic comedy it seems like each
character each sort of partner of this
dance is missing something in their
lives and they see at some point that
that other person is going to basically
cheer them of that why do we why do we
resonate with that and why is that such
a common theme there's another wonderful
Greek myth that says that originally
humans were both male and female
together and we had four legs and four
arms and two heads then we were joined
but with all those limbs humans were
able to start climbing up Mount Olympus
and were able to start challenging the
gods and the God said oh no that's we'll
never do
and so they tore humans apart and male
and female were separated and since then
it is the nature of our yearning to try
to reunite into the one form so that's
how a mythology set it up what we are
trying to do in romance is to find that
missing part of ourselves what I think
is interesting is that in some instances
people are trying to find that thing
that will compliment them because they
don't have it and then there are those
instances where somebody says oh you've
got that so much more than I do I'm
going to look a whole lot better than
you by comparison
you know if I'm cynical but you're more
cynical that's going to make me look
like the good guy so some of the
romantic comedies have that sort of a
mechanism in it but I think basically
what most of us are looking for in our
romantic situations is a completion what
we see in our romantic relationships is
often said to be a reflection of our
relationship with our higher spiritual
selves or with the higher energies or
with the cosmos that we we connect to
life through each other that we connect
to the one life by
relating closely to one person and so
the alchemy of love can actually truly
lift us up and that that is what a lot
of us are looking for even if we're not
conscious of it but we are looking for
that that that bliss that nirvana within
our love relationships and you may have
heard some version of this where people
say we kissed and the world disappeared
and we became gods you go oh yes please
that's wonderful and one of my favorite
authors Lawrence Durrell British author
author of the wonderful Alexandria
quartet which is all about love and one
of his characters makes a note and says
in loving Justine I was loving all women
because she stood for the female and so
I think that's what we do too even when
we don't realize that we just go oh I
love you we're also loving the essence
of love why so often opposites attract
why is it sort of the hero worshipper or
shy admirer and the you know sort of I
don't know if you want to say type a
sort of here I mean I'm thinking of
let's say Jerry Maguire yeah okay film
absolutely love uh-huh
but but that's a common scenario whether
it's one is the male when it's a few you
know that you can kind of switch who's
sort of a hero worshipper but why do we
love that scenario so much I think we
have to go back to evolutionary biology
and evolutionary psychology to truly
answer that in small groups of people
you do not want to have too much
interbreeding because it's not healthy
so you need to stir up the gene pool and
so there's a phrase the brother or the
other you're going to get a better
immune system and your offspring if
you're not mating with your relatives if
you go for the other that which is
different so you take that on up to
modern
and times and we're still being
influenced by that we still see the
other the person who is different from
us as more of a potential mate a lot of
that's just our biology psychology from
you know 200,000 years still working on
us but I also think it's part of the the
wonderful magnetism of passion and of
sex regardless of what gender the body
is to have the positive pole and the
negative pole that's when you get
magnetism you get to positive poles
together what happens nothing they repel
each other I you get positive and
negative together and then you get
sparks then you get the magnetic pull so
I think that part of that opposites
attract is built into human nature that
is trying to produce the best offspring
and part of it also is just our sense of
adventure
let's take Annie Hall if you have Woody
Allen's character who's kind of
self-effacing he's down on himself and
then Diane Keaton who's a breath of
fresh air she's in a great mood she you
know very open to life why does that
dynamic work well I would count her and
say it didn't actually work because they
broke up and she in spite of her seeming
self-confidence also had some problems
with her own self-worth and what she
wanted and what she thought she should
want but yes on the surface they're
opposites and they may attract and it's
fun and that's one of the most fun parts
about that romantic comedy but if you
look at it again I think you'll see that
there are a whole lot more alike at
heart than they are different I was
surprised at that when I went back and
watched it you know with an analytical
eye for the book
you